hey y'all do you love middle ground
i know i do did you know that every
purchase made at the jubilee shop helps
fund this show if you're looking for
ways to support jubilee and watch more
episodes of middle ground make sure you
check out our merch at
shop.jubileemedia.com
honestly every one of your purchases
goes such a long way and we're so
grateful for you
enjoy this episode when i hear the term
fat influencer i'm thinking like an
unhealthy standard being said i just i
just can't get behind
being complacent well i want to say that
it doesn't mean complacency
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is timothya and fitness has been
a huge part of my life and i love to
share what i know about it overall just
it's just a way of life my name is tyler
i'm a fat influencer and on my platform
i like to spread body positivity mental
health awareness and fashion looking
good while fat so when i think of the
word fat influencers i think of
influencers who are either promoting
others to be fat in the same sense that
fitness influencers promote fitness i
don't like people that obsess over being
fat just like i don't like people that
obsess over fitness i'm in my own
fitness journey and a lot of people like
it because i'm not the stereotypical
dude the misconception that the opposite
side has of me
is that i have some agenda to keep
people fat to promote obesity to tell
anybody anything about their size
step forward if you agree
i promote healthy standards as an
influencer
i think we need to discuss with healthy
means first because healthy means many
different things
so like what does health mean to you
guys
for me i don't focus on diet and weight
loss as a tool for health and how i
communicate that i focus on movement and
finding movement that works for you that
feels good and is sustainable in your
body because ultimately
my you know i think everybody would
agree movement is healthy exercise is
healthy in the fitness world
and i myself am a yoga instructor so i
kind of straddle both sides
i think there's an over emphasis on
physicality and diet and exercise
personally you know i'm a i'm a fat guy
and i've been tired of being a fat guy
and i've actually been told that my
approach to it is a little bit extreme
so you know i'll do like 24-hour fast
i'll do intermittent intermediate
fasting
liquid diets things like that some
people say it's an unhealthy habit they
say like i got an eating disorder but at
the same time i am seeing results i do
feel like i can run faster jump higher
um
walk longer i kind of feel like when i
hear the term fat influencer i'm
thinking like an unhealthy standard
being said you know i just i just can't
get behind
being complacent well i want to say that
it doesn't mean complacency right so a
little bit about me is that i was a
three sport athlete my almost my entire
life went to college and played a sport
um and then i decided i've always been
you know a big person and i was able to
manipulate my weight because i also
wrestled so i would bulk up for football
season lose her wrestling and rinse and
repeat because of that though now my
approach is really just about making
sure that you take care of your total
self so your mind and your body
and also just making sure that you check
in with you know medical professionals i
um i work in health care and so i don't
tend to take advice from people who are
not medical professionals and i would
just like to speak up um
like
we're all different yeah they're fat
influencers out there that have
unhealthy lifestyles that share it but
that's their lifestyle there are fat
influencers that are motivational that
are trying to lose weight um there are
fat influencers out there that just are
existing in this world and trying to
make it um accommodating to themselves
and people that look like them so there
are so many fat people in this world and
to like label them all a certain way or
to put them in a category where they
have to perform to make you feel
comfortable
is disingenuous it's not good well
that's what uh that's what kind of upset
me that's why i started my journey at
the end of the day was because you know
i was
depressed i lost my job
in the midst of kovid and i'm unhappy
with who i am
and then i see someone on on social
media that's like it's okay to be who
you are
and i was like you're you're telling me
that the way i feel
is okay
but at the end of the day i hate how i
feel and so it was kind about a protest
that i started this journey and i'm damn
glad i did at the end of the day you're
doing a disservice to the people around
you that care about you whether it be
close relatives society etc and to see
someone use a platform like that as a
fellow fat kid my entire life
it just pissed me off i hear what you're
saying and it's valid i've been fat my
entire life i was a fat kid fat teenager
fat adult just fat
and
that is not my story and i see that
played out over and over and over again
in the world in art and tv and movies
like the sad fat trope nobody's gonna
want you and that plays into the way we
treat fat people but that is not
everybody's story so to like i hear that
you were sad you were unhealthy you were
uncomfortable you were isolated like we
can all relate to that but that is not
the story of every fat person
i am on a journey to like myself in my
skin and that is something i believe is
obtainable through hard work and
dedication i mean nothing else worked
you know
loving yourself quote unquote made me
eat kfc three times a day
and gained a lot of weight and turned
sedentary hating myself
encouraged me to be different and
encouraged me
to change my life and as a result i've
influenced thousands of kids younger
than me's lives
fat shaming is worse than skinny shaming
when you fin shame somebody it is based
off of
aesthetic like oh you're so skinny
i wish i could be like that
i wish i could eat whatever i want and
stay skinny there are these some
assumptions we have about people in fat
bodies that we don't place on thin
people even if they're
thin beyond health
and it really
makes makes it so that fat people are
overlooked and it creates an environment
where it's okay to perpetuate
um
hate and even violence you know being
thin won't limit you from being able to
shop where you want to shop you can walk
into a clothing store get clothes right
off the rack um sometimes even have
access you could go up or down the rack
in my experience those are not my my my
options i shop online because i wear a
size 15 shoe
because i'm 6'2 and i have a very broad
body the skinny shaming you know there
is that backhanding compliment you know
you see that all the time but when it
comes to the fat shaming you just see
more negative out of it and i just you
know it's just it's it's horrible to see
but being fat is still taboo believe it
or not my partner and i i'm a gay man
dating another fat black cat fat black
gay man and we have gone viral on the
internet a couple times and you know
what some of the comments were i've
never seen two fat people together i get
pat's on the back for posting a picture
at the beach with no shirt on why am i
being patted on the back for that right
can they disagree or step forward
well when i hear fat shaming skinny
shaming all that stuff i just think back
to like middle school high school you
know picking on kids it's bullying i
believe everyone goes through body
dysmorphia one of my home girls is a is
a model and she's always complaining how
she doesn't like the way she looks even
though like 99 of all women would
probably prefer they look like her
she hates the way she looks and she's
like i wish my boobs were bigger i wish
my butt was bigger i believe you know
that's the media that's the
entertainment industry is they have a
standard of what
at the end of the day is
desired i guess but not everyone's built
like marilyn monroe you said 99 of women
would probably want to look like her
that's the to me some of the language
that is the problem
is that i'm assuming i'm assuming that
she's probably uh of a thinner body
right because she's a model but a lot of
women don't
it's okay your body is the you are the
standard you are the model you are the
beauty like the fact that we think like
that already is is still what the
problem is and it's still why to me fat
shaming is worse than
the skinny shaming because like even our
language i know people just desire this
really thin body you know it's like
that's the language in the language
when i get negative comments about my
relationship with my partner
i kind of like to troll back for example
if i tweet a picture of us kissing
or dancing um people will spew the
homophobic slurs and stuff so i like to
then just share more pictures of us
kissing and really double down into it
and let them know honey you know we're
here to stay the girls are not going
anywhere you know um and just letting
them know that i'm confident in myself
i'm happy i'm in love and i'm living my
life
i don't think i've ever been shamed
for my body i was always moving i was
always you know that i stayed fit my
whole life you know to be a fitness
influencer you have to have that image
that skinny fit tone look that's really
not the case if you have the knowledge
if you have the passion to want to help
people with their fitness journey it
doesn't matter i highly believe that
i feel pressure to look a certain way
for my followers
yeah you know i started
i'm i'm a i'm a fat kid losing weight
man you know i got an expectation to
uphold
you know i get i get people all the time
haters
that are like oh he's gonna quit crash
diet blah blah blah
but then you know there's kids that tell
me you know you got me out of bed today
you're the best person on the internet
like i love you if i can motivate
someone one person a day
to do something to to better themselves
i'm going to do everything in my power
to keep myself going and that means not
quitting and that means looking a
certain way always developing always
growing and you know because if i quit
i'm letting down thousands of people
i used to feel a lot of pressure but i
think with practice you
get over those pressures you learn
how to deal with it and understand that
the pressure is really from yourself
it's internalized like you're thinking
about what others think of you
when in reality they could care less
they don't even see the little the
little things that's exactly it i think
we should stop worrying about what other
people think but it's so hard i mean
like i could say that every day and it
is i still think about what people think
it is we all do we all do but that's
something that is a good challenge for
all of us you know that's something that
we need to
you really just try
and once we get on that road it's not
easy we're gonna have days where we're
just gonna be like oh she thinks i think
but if we can get past that even just a
little bit it's just gonna make our
lives even easier you know just stop
worrying about other people worry about
yourself yeah i also just feel like
you know like everybody else this is my
account and you are a guest here you
know
i have had to learn to not be that way
so and and for nick i understand that
you know your social media and your
journey is very different like i could
clearly see how people or your following
would have those expectations for you to
continue to lose the weight it's like
okay well we joined this guy so that we
could join his journey on his weight
loss so we only want to see him doing
the weight loss like you better not like
plateau or game you know i totally i
could definitely see that well it's a
it's a sense of accountability and it
really helps me
keep keep my [ __ ] going otherwise i
would have dropped out a long time ago
to be honest and i don't do like this is
how to do a curl and things like that i
just do like how i feel
i sort of a self-deprecating outlook on
myself and how i feel
and it's sort of like a military
style thing like your trash
like you will never be good just give up
type thing to myself
i think that's interesting that you say
that because
the content that i post is not just for
people it's mostly for me and it's part
of my own it's like it's cathartic to
see myself in like like sweating like
trying to do a headstand and falling
or looking glam for an event and like
and everything between so being
authentic and like showing up as i am
whether people like it or not or
expecting it or not is an exercise in
self-love it helps me accept myself
i was
really shy as a kid and also you know
overweight or fat i think the
misconception is that i wasn't
intelligent and that i was lazy like
that's a lot of the bullying i got right
yeah i don't think i dealt with it well
it wasn't until later in life where i
started to kind of
reject that narrative
weight loss programs are toxic
fitness promoters
are promoting these weight loss programs
or these diets that aren't working for
everyone
and it's kind of sad to see because it's
really affecting people and like the way
they see fitness and health and it's
toxic i think and the focus is always or
it seems to be like just just lose the
weight just lose the weight just lose
the weight and then you'll be happy and
everything will be okay and you'll feel
good and you'll fit into that but it's
like whoa
i can lose all that weight and i could
still be miserable personally in my
journey one of my biggest points is i do
not use a scale
because
goals to me are limitations
and when you hit that goal you get
comfortable
aka complacent you're like oh i'm gonna
lose 10 pounds and then i'm good
and so
i don't focus on the weight i focus on
everything else i focus on you know
getting out of bed that routine of going
to the gym the routine of eating healthy
that that normal feeling of like
a caloric deficit and things like that
that's a good way to do it too i tell
i'm i'm a fitness trainer too and i tell
my clients i'm like don't the scale
really doesn't tell you much you're
going to fluctuate water weights a lot
to it
you gotta look at yourself in the mirror
you gotta see those physical changes i
don't even think it's the physical
changes because i'm gonna be straight up
i probably had body dysmorphia for a
little bit and i would always like
check myself in the mirror you know like
after eating i would check myself
because i wanted to keep a six-pack
because the fitness industry
told me that i needed a six-pack you
hear a fitness influencer and like the
first thing you think is like weight
loss programs selling a program selling
the course and i purposely wore this
shirt this morning just to see like if
there would be any extra bias one thing
i noticed about fitness being in this
space for so long
is that just because you're into fitness
doesn't mean you're into health
i told everyone that i dealt with body
dysmorphia and i think in terms of
dealing with it it's just learning that
my
value is not
completely tied to my appearance there's
so many other things
that i have i can see value in myself
now uh i really do enjoy
the autonomy i have over my own health
and my own wellness
i have suffered from eating disorders
i didn't realize it until a couple years
after but i was tracking like every food
i did track calories macros
man i had my scale and i would bring it
like to the college's dining hall
uh i would like weigh everything
and they would get to the point where i
would either eat before going out like
if i knew my friends were gonna go out
to eat i would eat at home so i could
measure all the food out put it into my
fitness pal and then go out and not eat
with them or i would
probably just not go out at all
food and fitness really took over my
life for a few years
i was super super obsessed with just you
know getting that goal weight or looking
good and everything like that
and i found myself just super depressed
and i
you know didn't eat the foods i wanted
to eat and i over exercised and i wasn't
myself it was just a horrible point in
my life and i had to go see a doctor i
had to get that help mentally i wasn't
there
so
these things are real like this stuff
happens and people don't reach out
enough the last time i had really
restricted my eating i needed to lose
like
almost 30 pounds in like 11 days and um
i did that
and i stepped on the wrestling mat and i
had absolutely no strength i had no
energy no strength i got whooped i got
tossed up and down the mat
um and then after that i told myself
that i would never do it again but of
course out of bad habits i just picked
up another bad habit and then began to
enjoy binge eating
and then i was like okay well now i'm
not restricting anything and now
everything goes and how are you now now
i'm much better therapy medication
everyday practicing you know
doing the right kinds of things i'm much
better now
i suffer from suffered from an eating
disorder i had childhood trauma and it
took me until my adulthood to realize i
was pacifying with food and that's
something that was taught to me
and then on the other end of that with
extreme dieting like i did the hcg
protocol where you eat 500 calories a
day and give yourself an injection
for months on end and so i have done the
full spectrum uh the 500 calorie diet
was that something with like a medical
professional that they recommended
yeah
i love that like i can
it was traumatic it was it drove me into
um
a spiral like i can relate to what
you're saying about like bringing your
scale and eating before you went out
with your friends because that was me
it's really you know it's taken so much
time for me to get to a point to even
know what i like to eat and it took me
until like 25 30 to even realize okay i
don't actually like eating that i
actually don't like this i like this and
um it's been really healing to like
reclaim my relationship with food and to
say like okay this is what i like and
this is what makes me feel really good
uh as a fitness influencer what are some
things i can do
that helps out the other side which
would be fat influencers what are like
certain things that you guys promote
that you could see me promoting
i really really really really really
want people to stop looking at fat
people and all of a sudden becoming
medical professionals and telling me
about high blood pressure and diabetes
because again
you're not a medical professional right
like like
let's like let let the fat people do the
mukbangs too you know like if you want
to do one that is so cool but if a fat
person wants to do one let us just do it
in peace you know that would be my
takeaway because you never know what
we're doing behind the scenes you don't
know how many therapists how many
doctors dieticians you have no idea how
many things that you've had i want to
know a little bit more about the beauty
standard on you know we're in 2021 and
it's not like
back in the day now
are we making the right direction is
that is that good
i think it's reactive it's good like
visibility is important i've talked
about this before earlier i think that
we all deserve to be represented no
matter what we look like
no matter the status of our health we
should all see each other
ourselves in the world
um so i think yeah there is progress
being made there are brands that are
making sizes that more people can wear
we are seeing body diversity on
magazines and things like that but it's
very reactive and it's very tied into
commerce and marketing so
is it real i don't know
but
it's part of our culture and it's slowly
shifting
for whatever reason like regardless it
will eventually have an impact on
society as a whole so yes and no is it
going to promote people
to think it's okay to
be overweight here's the thing people
have been fat since people have existed
yeah
i don't think that showing us as we are
is going to have a negative impact we
are here we have always been here you
can go to the leruv and see sculptures
of fat people that people have always
been around being in a fitness
influencer it's good to see that
perspective from everyone too we all
have our differences but as long as we
stay on the path that we want to stay on
healthy mentally physically emotionally
we're gonna be okay and it's okay to get
help
it always is okay to get help thank you
so much everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
you